und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend wir machen das wirklich
ungern aber wir müssen doch wieder mit
dem corona thema in die sendung gehen es
hilft stellt sich raus nichts dass die
omikron variante nicht schwerer krank
macht als delta vielleicht sogar ein
bisschen weniger schwer entscheidend ist
dass omikron viel schneller viel mehr
menschen ansteckt als die früheren
varianten ein virus kann ein
gesundheitssystem mit der schieren
fallzahl in die knie zwingen so geht es
los twittert der virologe christian
drosten ohne premium fair beschreibt
schlicht den natürlichen vorgang viren
mikroskopisch kleine organismen sind
eine naturgewalt wahrscheinlich ist das
was mittlerweile in großbritannien sogar
die regierung johnson aufschreckt der
entwicklung auf dem kontinent nur ein
kleines stück voraus andreas stamm
berichtet
der blick in eine postfiliale genügt um
zu erahnen was los ist corona tests
statt weihnachtsbriefe bringen das
verteilsystem an den rand des
zusammenbruchs der drohe auch den
krankenhäusern wegen omikron wenn nicht
schnell gehandelt werde kontakt
beschränkungen etwa was treffen in
innenräumen angehe so die
wissenschaftlichen berater der regierung
was am wichtigsten ist dass wir noch
mehr menschen impfen aber wir haben es
schleifen lassen und nun reicht das
nicht wir könnten uns im januar in einer
furchtbaren situation wiederfinden
entscheidend werde sein ob omikron
milder verlaufen oder nicht die
regierung hat zwar das booster programm
hochgefahren mehr als 800 tausend
nadelstiche am tag doch zu wenig so die
experten solange veranstaltungen wie die
darts wm weiter liefen oder volle
stadien bei fußballspielen
und genau in der premier league zeigt
sich wie schnell omikron sich verbreitet
wegen zu vielen erkrankten spielern
wurden jetzt sechs von zehn wochenend
partien abgesagt die enorme
ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit zeigt diese
grafik basierend auf zahlen einer
britischen gesundheitsbehörde die
infektion mit delta blieben in london
über wochen recht stabil mit dem
november taucht omikron auf die variante
lässt seit anfang dezember die zahlen in
die höhe schießen
am nachmittag rief der bürgermeister für
den omikron hotspot den katastrophenfall
aus
die zahl der krankenhauseinweisungen
steigt nun ebenfalls noch vor wenigen
wochen hatten wir die wenigsten fälle im
land nun sind wir die region mit den
meisten und die zahl der infizierten
londoner wird so schnell so groß dass
sich immer mehr krank melden das
gefährdet die funktionsfähigkeit etwa
von polizei oder feuerwehr und ganz
speziell habe ich die sorge über den
wachsenden personalmangel im
gesundheitssystem
für morgen ist ein treffen des
nationalen sicherheitsrats geplant über
maßnahmen bis hin zu einem lockdown
werde diskutiert doch premierminister
johnson konnte in dieser woche moderator
einschränkungen nur mit hilfe der
opposition durchsetzen einmal mehr
könnte der premier den zeitpunkt für
härtere maßnahmen verpassen zum schaden
des landes nur eins hat wenig gebracht
grenzen dichtmachen omikron sollte
draußen bleiben der flugverkehr mit dem
südlichen afrika wurde eingestellt der
erste gedanke der politisch
verantwortlichen und 14 tage später
mitte dieser woche wurde die maßnahme
wieder zurückgenommen es sei sinnlos
geworden staaten noch rote listen zu
setzen erklärte der gesundheitsminister
denn ist omikron angekommen beginnt es
seinen siegeszug
genau deshalb hat die bundesregierung
jetzt die britischen inseln als
varianten gebiet eingestuftes bedeutet
man kann von dort nur noch nach
deutschland deutschland einreisen mit
einem pcr-test plus man muss dann 14
tage in quarantäne
eine quarantäne aus dem man auch nicht
mit einem test wieder raus kommt eine
erhebliche erschwerung auf dem kontinent
hat der beginn der egal ob der omicron
variante die regierung der niederlande
jetzt einem schweren weil sehr
unpopulären schritt gezwungen ab morgen
früh geht das land in einen harten
lockdown schlagartig schluss heißt das
mit weihnachtseinkäufen und großen
familientreffen bis mitte januar eine
warum so plötzlich und warum so hart
weil die niederländische regierung
offenbar die ausbreitung der omicron
variante unterschätzt hatte man war auch
ähnlich wie in deutschland mit der
bildung einer neuen koalitionsregierung
beschäftigt und insgesamt gingen die
infektionszahlen in den niederladen
runter aber in den niederlanden runter
aber jetzt haben die experten die die
niederländische regierung beraten alarm
geschlagen denn in amsterdam verdoppeln
sich die infektionszahlen alle zwei bis
drei tage und schon jede vierte
infektion geht in amsterdam auf die
omikron variante zurück die schon vor
weihnachten also bis nächste woche die
dominante variante in amsterdam sein
könnte dazu kommt dass die niederlande
bei den auffrischungsimpfungen
ziemlich zurück liegen sie fangen jetzt
erst an menschen über 65 zum dritten mal
zu impfen auch deshalb ist die sorge
groß wie kommt das denn anders gab ja
schon proteste gegen die korona
schutzmaßnahmen in den niederlanden
bevor diese drastische maßnahme im
grunde stillstand des landes vor
weihnachten einschließlich
weihnachtsfeier und im familienkreis den
kaum noch möglich beschlossen wurden
gerade eben also erst mal sind die
niederländer nachdem sich das heute
morgen und bis heute mittag
herumgesprochen hatte dass ein lockdown
kommt in die innenstädte gestürmt um
schnell noch weihnachtsgeschenke zu
kaufen und diesen samstag sozusagen noch
einmal zu einem super sprayer event zu
machen insgesamt muss man sagen dass die
niederländer mit einer mischung aus
erleichterung und entsetzen reagiert
haben auf diesen lockdown denn die
regierung rutte fährt ja schon seit
beginn der pandemie einen zick-zack-kurs
es gab mehrere harte maßnahmen und schon
zweimal hatte der premierminister auch
die pandemie im sommer und im herbst für
beendet erklärt jetzt also eine erneute
rolle rückwärts der regierung rutte von
deutschland gesehen ganz nebenan
dankeschön an die nachrichten aus dem
nahen europäischen ausland haben
offenbar diejenigen nicht der reicht die
in deutschen städten heute
demonstrationen gegen die korona
schutzmaßnahmen veranstalteten diese
szene wächst wird breiter lauter und
zeigt in ihren extremen bereitschaft zur
gewalt in göppingen lud die alternative
für deutschland zu einer kundgebung für
die freiheit wie es hieß und gegen
impfpflicht bevormundung und lockdown
ein rund 600 impfgegner kommen
sprechchöre fordern den rücktritt des
oberbürgermeisters
in neumarkt like laut polizei sind es
2300 impfgegner die meisten kamen am
abend in hamburg zusammen unter dem
motto das maß ist voll hände weg von
unseren kindern sind dort nach
schätzungen der polizei mehr als 11.000
demonstrierende unterwegs vielerorts
konnte sich gegen protest und es blieb
wohl überwiegend friedlich im osten
thüringens in der stadt greiz die sich
perle des vogtlands nennen lässt haben
heute bürger und bürgerinnen von sich
hören lassen friedlich musik gegen die
gewalt die letzten samstag in greiz auf
corona demonstrationen durchbrach 14
polizisten wurden verletzt melanie hug
und johanna kießler bericht
bereits dreht die lautsprecher auf
mit friedens liedern die am abend vom
dach der vogtlandhalle tönen eine aktion
die frieden stiften soll in ihrer stadt
in der auch heute wieder zu so genannten
spaziergängen aufgerufen wurde wir haben
die idee dass wir das es vielleicht
schön wäre einfach mal ein element zu
spielen was jeden betrifft und berührt
nämlich musik und haben festgestellt
dass alles so froh sind das wirklich
auch meine stimme kommt die für sie
spricht und zwar für die menschen die
eben nicht auf der straße waren und die
eben überhaupt nicht einverstanden sind
auch mit diesen gewaltvollen szenen es
sind vereine kirchen firmen die den
andauernden protesten etwas
entgegensetzen wollen proteste die
letzten samstag eskalierte nicht nur 14
verletzte polizisten auch verängstigte
kinder die an diesem abend eine ihrer
aufführungen des weihnachtsmärchens in
der vogtlandhalle gehabt hätten die
vorstellung mussten sie kurzfristig
absagen man ist einfach fassungsloser
man hier in seinem haus eingekesselt ist
mit kinder und nicht mehr raus kann
draußen laufen vermummte es gab donner
die geschmissen wurden das war einfach
so der moment wo wir gesagt haben
irgendwas müssen wir jetzt zeigen das
ist ja nicht mehr das bild was wir von
unserer heimatstadt haben und auf was
wir auch unser engagement aufbauen
können
deshalb seien die friedenslieder ein
richtiges zeichen dass ihr theater
unterstützt bereits die stadt mit ihrem
schloss und sommerpalais die sich selbst
gern perle des vogtlands nennt sucht
antworten
thomas schäfer hat eine brauerei in
greiz und seit vielen monaten einbußen
bei seine kunden wegbrechen frust hatte
auch nur habe der seine grenzen die
leute haben angst
vom impfen gastronomen sind betroffen
dass die kneipen so gut wie zu sehen
weil und der zweig natürlich auch
weniger kunden zu ihnen kommen und dass
man dagegen demonstriert habe ich
absolutes verständnis wo ich halt kein
verständnis dafür hat dass sich dann
leute anschließend die einfach nur auf
randale aus sind deshalb unterstützt
auch er die aktionen gegen die gewalt in
seiner stadt heute abend sind es nicht
nur lieder diese figuren sollen für die
stille mehrheit stehen letztendlich sind
wir menschen und am ende dieser pandemie
müssen uns in die augen gucken können
und irgendwie wieder zueinander finden
an diesem abend blieb es ruhig in greiz
und
die nachrichten schließen hier an ja
auch österreich verschärft die einreise
regeln um die omikron variante
einzudämmen schon ab montag dürfen nur
noch dreifach geimpfte und genesene ins
land werk eine auffrischimpfung hat muss
ebenso wie die genesenen einen pcr-test
vorlegen das wird auch viele deutsche
skiurlauber treffen die nach österreich
wollen die aktuellen corona zahlen in
deutschland gehen weiter zurück auch die
hospitalisierung rate bundesweit sind
5,1 menschen pro 100.000 einwohner
binnen sieben tagen wegen des virus im
krankenhaus die sieben tage inzidenz ist
auf 321 8 gesunken das rkw meldete 42
1813 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
zehn
1884 weniger als vor einer woche hoch
bleibt die zahl der gemeldeten corona
todesfälle
414 kamen hinzu
knapp ein jahr nach der erstürmung des
us capitols durch anhänger von
ex-präsident trump hat ein gericht in
washington die bislang härteste
haftstrafe verhängt ein mann aus florida
muss mehr als fünf jahre in haft weil er
polizisten attackiert hatte bei dem
angriff auf den sitz des amerikanischen
parlaments anfang januar waren fünf
menschen ums leben gekommen mehr als 700
beteiligte wurden seither angeklagt
man kann dem präsidenten der türkei
anerkennung nicht verweigern das harzer
handwerk autoritärer herrschaft
beherrscht erdogan wie nur wenige er hat
die aufbegehrende jugend zum schweigen
und die opposition zu großen teilen
hinter gitter gebracht er hat seine
früheren verbündeten von der
islamistischen gülen bewegung zu
zehntausenden um ihre arbeit ihr
eigentum und ihre freiheit gebracht die
nationalistischen militärs entmachtet
und er lässt die presse nach seiner
pfeife tanzen sie mal zumeist erdogans
bild von einer blühenden türkei fakten
beugen sich dem herrscher willen so
sieht das aus jetzt versucht er das
gleiche mit den gesetzen der wirtschaft
und des kapitals und da beißt er sich
gerade die zähne aus wobei die folgen
spüren die beherrschten viel mehr als
der herrscher noch jörg brase berichtet
die türkische lira fällt der umsatz in
der grenzstadt edel steigt für die eu
nachbarn aus bulgarien ist die türkei
das einkaufsparadies shopping touristen
packen ein was sie tragen können für
einen euro bekommt man mehr als 18
lehrer wann hat es das schon mal gegeben
für uns ist das toll aber für die türkei
wohl eher nicht für das türkische volk
ist es schlecht
viele ladenbesitzer freut der reißende
absatz doch lange nicht alle
das tut weh du kannst denn dann im
eigenen land nicht einkaufen weil die
preise zu hoch sind aber die ausländer
kaufen ein ganzes land leer es ist
leider die realität und wird sich so
schnell nicht
seit monaten steigen die preise
21 prozent inflation das ist die
offizielle zahl doch unabhängige
wirtschaftswissenschaftler haben einen
preisanstieg errechnet der dreimal so
hoch liegt wie die zahlen der regierung
sie hat das spiel seiner fraktion liegt
nach unseren zahlen bei rund 60 prozent
um genau zu sein
58,65 und wir gehen davon aus dass diese
zahl noch steigen
einen grund für die krise sehen experten
auch im einfluss des präsidenten auf die
zinspolitik der doch eigentlich
unabhängigen zentralbank erdogan feierte
bereits mehrere zentralbankchefs zwingt
die notenbank immer wieder zu
zinssenkungen
jeder weiß dass ich kein freund hoher
zinsen war und ich werde das auch nie
sein war damit dass ein für alle mal
klar
[Applaus]
erdogans volk aber leidet schlangen vor
der staatlichen brot ausgabe und als ich
nun auch erste straßenproteste legten
verkündete der präsident stolz dass er
den staatlichen mindestlohn angehoben
habe um 50 prozent auf 5 230 euro in
ich hoffe dass der neue mindestlohn den
arbeitnehmern glück bringen wird wir
werden nicht zulassen dass unsere
arbeitnehmer unter den steigenden
preisen erdrückt werden
doch das glücksversprechen ihres
präsidenten reicht vielen nicht mehr aus
die könnten den mindestlohn auf 4 500
euro erhöhen das hilft nichts wenn die
inflation doppelt oder dreimal sie auf
ist mit jedem neuen rekordtief der lira
und jedem neuen rekordhoch der preise
und die stimmung der menschen im land
immer schlechter
der richtige tipp in der europäischen
lotterie eurojackpot hat eine schöne
bescherung ermöglicht mehr als 73
millionen euro dieser hauptgewinn geht
nach nordrhein westfalen an jemanden der
oder die 18 eur 75 für das los
investiert hatte
die gewinnzahlen von heute 10 16 25 28
43 46 die superzahl 8 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 6 das wetter in den
tagen bis weihnachten wird doch noch
winterlicher morgen aber bleibt es
überwiegend trüb wolkenlücken nur im
südwesten und in küstennähe im nordosten
etwas regen bei kräftigem nordwestwind
bei 1 bis 9 grad in der neuen woche gibt
es mehr sonne erst mal selten schauer
und es wird kälter ab dienstag nur noch
zwischen minus zwei und plus 5 grad und
alles vom sport gleich im sportstudio in
dem alexander zverev zu gast ist und
morgen abend bis fast weihnachten sind
marita und kein server an diesen plätzen
hier wir wünschen ihnen einen schönen
vierten advent
[Musik]